more people are escaping war
but getting to safety means risking your
life
active conflict zones russian
checkpoints ukrainians say it's
difficult to know which way is safe
the blockade of mario paul will go down
in history of responsibility for war
crimes
to do this to a peaceful city what the
occupiers did it is terror that will be
remembered for centuries to come
and the more ukrainians tell the world
about it
the more support we will find
the more russia uses terror against
ukraine the worse the consequences will
be for it
in a recent address zelinski warned
russian soldiers death awaits them in
ukraine noting recent russian failures
on the battlefield
and thousands of people who have fled
war-torn cities
ukrainian resolve
in the face of continued russian strikes
recovery work is ongoing in mikolayev a
russian strike on friday killed dozens
of ukrainian soldiers asleep in their
bunks
and still no news of the 1 300 people
believed to be trapped under the rubble
of mariopol theater bombed four days ago
control of this strategic city is still
heavily contested by both sides
and overnight in kharkiv more shelling
more destruction
evacuations have been stepped up so have
preparations at the largest reception
center in la vie
thousands of people have come and gone
volunteers are preparing to receive and
relocate thousands more in the coming
days
now we're expecting people from mario
paul we're preparing places for them to
relax get food stay for a time and go
further to other regions or abroad
one family from a village near kiev said
the worst part of their journey was
witnessing the horrors of war
we were passing through a russian
checkpoint and saw a lot of bodies lying
near the road some of them were shot
some missing body parts
at one checkpoint in the village we were
waiting for two buses that were part of
our convoy but they were all gunned down
by pro-russian forces at another village
pro-russian chechen fighters hold people
hostage they say
knowing ukrainian military will not
shoot at civilians
what can i say she says i'm scared a lot
i don't want to leave
they are safe for now
together
warm
happy
but once his family is in poland
vladislav says he will go back to fight
zayn basravi al-jazeera love